hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close i am
your co-host gio and i'm bart and today
we have one of yours and my favorite
guest back we have thatch in the house
thank you so much for being back uh this
is gonna be a super fun video the other
video if you didn't catch it please
watch it it's very heartfelt you're
gonna learn so much more than any book
or any school or anything i'll ever
teach you so make sure to listen to that
podcast um but in this uh episode we are
going to you guys the questions that you
guys wanted to ask thatch yourself um
and bart's gonna kick it off i actually
have my
own first question you cheater cause
we're just all talking outside and you
were talking about how you got into um
almost going to prison because of what
happened or like a real estate or
something like what what was that story
yeah you know again this is one of my
pivoting point in my life you know what
i mean finding clear to my life i'm a
big believer that
we have to go through
uh [ __ ] up to find clarity yeah we got
to go through breakdown to have
breakthrough we have to go through what
i call contrast right to find uh purpose
and clarity
and um
i sold one of my friend called me and he
said hey man i want to sell my house so
i go to their house and list their house
and i put it on the market and he called
me hey man what did my friend want to
buy at my house
can you write it up no problem and uh he
and then i met his friend his friend
said hey my credit shot can you maybe
put in this guy's name so i told the guy
go get pre-approved when you get
pre-approved and if you can buy it i
have no problem writing it up the guy
got pre-approved right and uh and you
know back then you can do state alone
right with 25 down
no credit no problem right
two year later
right you can't do that anymore you
can't do that anymore you need credit i
see right
um
i'm my work and i get a page hey thatch
come to the front desk i get to the
front desk
and i get up there and uh and then there
were these two people there and i said
can we speak to you privately i'm like
okay
i go into a private office and the guy
said hi my name is blaine blank i work
for fbi
and she is blank blank she was for irs
oh [ __ ] and my heart was just like
dropped at that time and i was already
successful at the time you know what i
mean i just moved into this new office
you know and i just felt a little
embarrassed you know them at the same
time
and i like what's the problem i was like
well we just picked up this guy from
california
with 25 kilos of cocaine oh my god
and we've been doing investigation on
him and who all the people associating
with him and we're taking down a lot of
people who've been associated with him
and you're one of the person we noticed
that sold him a house
god damn and i like yes what's the
problem
we believe
that you know he's a drug dealer and you
still stole the house
in the federal system that's called
money laundering and that's called
conspiracy
and
we are planning to indict you uh for
conspiracy and that's 15 years in the
penitentiary oh my god you and yourself
well at that time
right at the time i wasn't married to
camera yet right
and um and um basically i went and hired
an attorney i didn't know where to look
for somebody referred me a really good
attorney which is the manager of that
office he go see my friend i went to see
him i remember the next day right uh um
i went to see the attorney and turned
the call up the fans and said hey man
from now on that was my client talk to
me
and i remember this is what i would say
to people too
make sure when you guys are working
don't spend all your money make sure you
have money saved because you never know
when the rainy day will come yeah you
never know and it can come in the
weirdest forms all on the forum the guy
says
you're gonna have a little bit of
problem
because you hang out and associate with
a lot of great people in the
neighborhood where you grew up and
there's good people there right and but
there's also a judgment of these people
probably are drug dealers and not
everybody drug dealer in south seattle
and so the feds is going to try to pin
you for you know you hang out with drug
dealers
even though you're successful real
estate agent right and legit and you're
legit but it's the association they're
going to try to get you for yeah so
you're going to just like homies that
you grew up with yeah right yeah now the
guy who i showed house to i don't know
the guy i see you see what i mean yeah
so
you're going to need an uh somebody
representative you but you're cammy i
can't do both of you guys i'm gonna have
to refer you to one of my other uh uh uh
uh uh clients right in the office and to
get started we need a fifteen thousand
dollar non-refund refundable retaining
fee for each person oh 30 grand 30 grand
and this is in 1995 bro
i was just you know i mean becoming
successful yeah and thank god i was
saving money early okay imagine you
didn't have it what is that now 30 grand
50 grand probably 100 grand probably
yeah i mean
you talk about big big dog it's a big
dog okay yeah and so for two years
okay
what the fed does is they actually take
cameo kamian to the grand jury
and the grand jury your her attorney
cannot go inside the the court oh [ __ ]
because
everything you say in the grand jury
cannot be held against you but
everything you say in the grand jury you
gotta be consistent we go to trial i see
so that's the tricky thing yeah yeah but
we are clean so everything we say is
clean so we don't have to worry about
covering our tracks i see but at the
same time my attorney says to me you got
to keep going out there and sell and
door knocking and go out there and sell
how is this like you've been selling 50
80 homes a year because you stopped
selling that many home
they're gonna think you all the home you
sell was drug dealer oh my god so i want
you to think about here as cammy at the
grand jury in the grand jury the hurt
sitting outside
i'm out door knocking
right looking for more deal
with the mindset of
why should i keep going door knocking
other than i got to do it to prove my
innocent i don't sell home to drug
dealer
and everything i was making that goes to
my bank up there froze my money so i
can't use it if i go to trial
so for two years
it was like that
so you had enough savings to last two
years well i could use it to pay my my
bill i can't use it to do anything else
you know what i mean yeah right if i use
it to like flip houses or investments
yeah or okay if i have to go do a trial
you know what i mean yeah
and so i lived in my mom and dad's house
and uh my attorney said you can't tell
nobody what you're going through because
we want to keep it undercover so it was
on me and cami going through this hard
stuff during our time oh my god keep it
to ourselves
so she was going through the grand jury
about probably 16 12 months
and i'm out here door knocking
and then finally
he said i'll give you immunity if you
[ __ ] tell us the truth and her turn
is like okay
all right sign it
that they signed it cammy went
for the last time and told him the same
ass story again and it was pissed
so then they says thatch
we're gonna come out detach on monday
this is like on wednesday or thursday
and so friday me and cami
um decided to go to vancouver to
strategize and we were like look honey
they want to take me in
if for some reason i don't come back out
and i'll go spend 15 years god damn
let's talk about the worst case scenario
the worst case scenario i'm gonna
give you power fraternity for my name so
if anything you got to sell and make it
might you know to get rid of the real
estate so you can live right because he
was still working a safe way right
he didn't work with me yet
then you just sell the property you need
to don't worry about me okay this is
before you guys are even married yes
it's tight
before
you knew you guys were gonna get married
though oh yeah the shoes and one right i
see dan i said to her the worst
and then if you need to sell it sell it
then the worst case
if
the worst case i don't come out for 15
years
oh my god and you
need to move on
you have the right to move on
you don't have to wait until i get out
damn
if this is the worst case let's make
peace with it
so then i can go in
i don't have to worry about anything
yeah you just do what you got to do and
we already agreed on this already
if that's the worst case let's agree on
this and we have to walk our way through
the worst case all the way to the bottom
yeah so we can have peace of mind both
of us yeah
because i know if i went in there i
don't come back out either
then we need to also have that
conversation yeah and so we have that
conversation
and we make peace with it and then on
our way driving back home being ready to
get picked up on monday
i just felt free man i just felt the sky
opened up
and i'm at home waiting for them to come
get me on monday the feds
they didn't come on monday
they didn't come on tuesday
uh did he come on friday
they didn't come next month
my attorney called me like a couple
weeks after i've been waiting and they
said i don't know they told me they're
gonna come get you
this i've been in this business 15 20
years and when they say they're gonna
come get you they come get you and i
don't know why they have not come got
you
and that was my pivoting point i
realized
when you make peace with the worst case
scenario you stop attracting the worst
case scenario in your life
if you don't make peace
you're already imprisoning yourself
anyways by just thinking about the worst
thing that's happening every day when
you make peace with everything you stop
focusing on putting your energy on the
worst case and all i was focusing on
was spending time on my family taking
them to family trips that's all i focus
on
and from this day
they steal having cane
damn that's awesome that's the power
of law of attraction damn well and not
doing some dirty [ __ ] right
on on sunday did you guys have sex one
last time that's right
hey yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's tight all right so did you get
your question out of the way all right
so now we're moving on to your guys's
questions okay thatch
could you explain how a 20 year old with
little to no money can begin financing
his first asset yes
so
sometime when you're young you don't
have
credit established yet
or you haven't worked out a job that
paid enough money where you can have
your income
that the bank will finance you so you
can actually have your first real estate
piece of property do you live in it or
you're going to keep it as a rental
because from the bank's perspective that
you need a track record these two years
to prove that if i give you this money
you're going to pay that's right and
you're capable of paying it back capable
so i'll say to the young people
what you got to do whatever you do for a
living
go ahead and
make your money but the most important
thing
you have to practice
right patient
you can't always have stuff instantly
okay practice save your money while i
tell my kids save your money
if your credit is messed up go get it
clean
keep your debt down
and then save your money because if
you're a first time home buyer you can
buy with three and a half percent down
you move into the property
and if you want
right
you can live there or you can stay at
home like me and you turn into a rental
property then you build your first asset
and from there
your property appreciate you make more
money you can pull a little bit of money
out and then buy the next one and the
next one the next one and that's how a
young person can actually start with
very little money nice is there a
percentage that you recommend for people
to save like let's say they make however
much is it like five percent ten percent
fifty percent all right so your first
time when your first time home buyer you
say you buy a house a five dollar all
you need is three nine percent down
which is a little less than twenty grand
most people can save that they really
put their mind to it
my kids russell and hudson got 13 14 000
you know i mean save and they're they're
young okay
so um and then when you buy your house
you want to have probably you know
six months ideally in reserve
that's good that's okay but most people
never tell you that because they all
talk you know always leverage leverage
leverage so the reserve is important if
you are going to do real estate in in
terms of in case you don't rent it out
you can still afford the payments for
six months that's right oh i see that's
right right so that's that's a tip that
i call you can buy it first home buyer
if you don't want to live in it i lived
in my mom and that's house and i have 15
rental property
i just kept doing it over and over and
over man good thing you'd love your
parents mexican i couldn't wait a movie
but that's the true way to save that's a
true absolutely you ain't paying [ __ ]
you got to get creative it's happened to
your resources and that's the best way
to expand like i always say man if you
don't teach your kid how to be creative
now when they get to that point they got
to learn how to be creative learn it now
early yeah right yeah yeah that's a good
that's some good tips okay next question
what was your biggest failure and how
did you recover from it um
god so many
so many man so many that's what i
realized too the more successful you are
the more failures you have actually yeah
and sometimes it's just even personal
failure you know what i mean yeah right
and then you have to be money failure
interpersonal failures so many things
man let me see which one i mean i got
i say one of my let me answer like this
one of my biggest failure
that i went through that got me
to
playing big today
okay
um
i remember
i was selling real estate making good
money i would build a single family home
and then one of my friends said hey man
you should partner with me we should
build big apartment buildings
you know real estate you have money you
have network network we can raise money
we can actually you know build real a
big apartment building and at that time
i i would say i was probably if i got
honest
two or three years ahead of my self
i was like okay let's do it like your
abilities yeah my abilities you know
what i mean yeah you overestimate what
your abilities are that's right right
and i i just did it because i was like
let's play b and i always tell people
sometimes it's okay
to
take a little bit of time because
everybody want to play
they like to get their skis in front of
them a little bit too far you know what
i mean yeah
so we started and we went and bought
this piece of land
for eight million dollar
i raised
pretty much
six million of that eight million of my
own friends and families
and my partner raised the other two
million and we built this 251 unit
apartment building in downtown seattle
we built us the condominiums okay
and we had a big event there
and we pre-sold 250 one unit in the
first week nice wow it was in 2006 and
it's gonna take two years to build this
building
it was already permitted ready to go
and then at the beginning of 2008 coming
in towards the end the building's almost
done the market turned in 2008. oh yeah
right and
um
about mid year of 2008
200 of the 250 sales they would draw
their offer oh my god you got to earn
this money back because you can do that
when you do of medium right because they
they don't lose your money until the end
when you sign this thing called public
offering statement and that don't get
provided to the end when the building is
done
so middle to a 200 sale they all pull
out literally in 30 days and it has 51
sale left only oh my and the market now
has been literally went soft yeah
and you couldn't sell 200 unit in six
months to save this building
and i was stressed out all my friends
money and i'm stressing i'm stressing
me and kami went we went meditating and
then on our way to work one day we were
driving without this light and cammy
she's way more alert than me she turned
to the corner on the sidewalk and it was
just a board and it says carbon 57
for rent and car 57 with my friend
building jim potter's building was a
condo meeting building mine was kind of
a building also and he's renting his
building out
oh
and when your mind is quiet
and just don't have a lot of [ __ ] going
on you can see messages from the
universe yeah and the message was rent
your building out
yeah and so we went to the bank say look
the market's soft
gave us an extension on the construction
loan for one year let us turn it into a
rental
after a couple weeks they say fine we
got it all rented out in one year
and now it's 2010
now the bank
started failing out there remember yep
yeah
we went to the bank says all leased up
now
give us a permanent financing and they
said sorry
all banks getting bought out by another
bank they don't know you guys and they
says
nope they want the loan you got 90 days
to either come up with the cash
or sell the building or we're going to
repo your building oh my god [ __ ]
right damn i got dramas and dramas for
you guys okay
and so
we meditated again and was like okay
let's put it on the market
we put it on the market
and we just well the sale we had the
market for apartment was just bending
the corner and all these
investors you know all the big
hits man wanted to buy it and we sold it
and we broke even we had 49 million
until he was over 50 million
and
50 million after about all the fees and
everything uh we paid back the bank in
full but all the investors got a 25
haircut
and during the whole time for two years
you guys i meditated and i said
i am going to make my investor hold some
way they are not gonna lose their money
right and i'm gonna bring back this
check for them they i'm a person
delivered to them in their hand and you
know what when they sold you guys even
though we got a 25 haircut when i went
back and gave the money to my investor
they said to me
we love you because you didn't give up
and you still gave it back or 75 into
our eyes
anytime you ever need money you come
back to us damn that's awesome and
that's one of the biggest thing i
learned
was integrity yeah yeah i made a promise
and i want to do what it takes to
deliver it dude it's all that minds that
you talk about because i asked you about
regret yeah and you flipped it and you
were like this is the best greatest
lesson i have ever learned yeah that's
tight that's why you'll never fail
integrity is the biggest thing man yeah
you ain't got integrity you got nothing
that's true i agree my dad that's one
thing uh my dad always told me he's like
if you have no word
you have nothing nothing
today that's why i got so many investors
what invested me but you know today i
have money now i don't need nobody and i
have more people coming to me now that
want to invest in me than ever but i
don't need their money damn and that's
even makes it even like more crazy yeah
yeah crazy yeah but anybody that get
involved with me anything i do
and again i always check my core value
if i feel like they're the right people
and do things if i like my qualified i
do it and if i'm doing it we're going to
go all the way to the finish line
together that's tight i love that
i love that that's awesome yeah we like
to live by that too yeah
okay next question is it dumb to pay the
pmi if you don't have twenty percent
down um pmi too he's saying uh and then
they were at well i don't know if this
is only applies in texas because i guess
they're from texas yeah peonies have a
principal interest
no what i would do
okay
is
if you don't have twenty percent just
still buy the house
okay
three and a half percent
right you you're gonna have to pay a
little bit principal interest is it
insurance uh principle and interest
right because if you don't have 20
percent you have this you got this uh
insurance that insurance is insured the
money right yeah
after you get 20 equity in your property
you can remove the
i see that the uh the uh uh insurance uh
yeah mortgage insurance yeah okay
homework insurance so you buy it then
you let it ride
and with the market how it is people can
instantly get their 20 in equity in
their property pretty quick the moment i
hit 20 percent then you can actually
call the bank and ask them to take out
the mortgage insurance and then now you
don't have to pay the mortgage no more
are you good that's awesome oh that is
awesome how long does it take for your
equity uh to get like 20 equity usually
look at your house yeah yeah it depends
right depending where you the market and
what you bought you know what i mean
that's true i mean with the market how
it is you know what i mean yeah uh i
mean people are getting you know time
for equity man within less than a year
yeah crazy that is crazy yeah since
we're talking about the market here's
the next question do you think that the
housing market will get cheaper in the
next few years no
there right now
because there's a lot of people that i
also know
they're sitting on money and they're
waiting for the market to crash and jump
in yeah because it feels like it's been
going you know straight up the whole
time so everyone's like there's got to
be a correction maybe in two like how
there was in 2008 they're not going to
have the correction like 208 where the
bank was making fake loans
so many people lost their house and then
short sale everything and then it
crashed and home became cheaper right
yeah
now there's a lot of people buying with
equity
i see there's a lot of people buying
houses out there with equity so i don't
think the market's gonna crash okay
here's the biggest reason why
there is
so many people
that are out there still looking to buy
okay
the problem right now in the united
states there is not enough new home
for the population growth
so new builder they have to constantly
go out there and find land to build to
keep up with the growth
when when the new construction property
continue to keep growing the old houses
grow with it because it's part of it so
we right now they say that we are so far
behind
put on enough house for populating
growth
for a long time like 10 plus years 20
years wow far okay so they need a lot of
houses
and so they're gonna they're gonna need
them and so
with anything right now the market's
gonna cool down it's gonna flatten out
for a while and it's gonna go back up
again so
if you look at all the history real
estate it's always been up
up flat up flat and the only time we
ever dipped like when that was 20 market
which was all you know all fake
stimulant market yeah but i don't think
it's going to go down in 2008 so i think
if anybody's gonna buy
what i tell people there's two type of
property to buy property that's already
turnkey ready to go in move in or
property you can buy in rehab and add
value
i teach people
if you want to buy property especially
investment property go buy a property
that need work so you buy at a lower
price add your equity in it when you get
done it's worth as much as a nice house
but you got instant equity
and then you're always outperforming the
market because you're buying it below
the market do you have a question yeah
that's smart like that how do you find
good contractors to help like do the
whole sweat equity stuff referrals uh
all through referrals gotcha right don't
ever look through a yellow page
get someone that has already worked with
the person they have experienced them
many times and then when you talk to
them you go interview them you go look
at their house you go look at their work
you go you know check out the finishing
right
then
but at the end of the day you can do all
that but the only really way you're
gonna know you gotta get in bed with him
at least once yeah so that you know this
person's legit you get in bed with them
i'm not gonna do it
i love you in bed
okay here's another question um how to
beat the chinese money when it comes to
buying real estate goddammit
i thought they were putting like bands
on the chinese like bringing so much
money they are making it tougher right
what the what they want
is they want turnkey nice luxury
property um
it's just they're using it just to it's
this safe deposit box money yeah yeah
they got a lot of money they don't buy
the stuff every day people buy yeah the
nice expensive home you know what i mean
yeah to park their money pay cash for it
yeah right so if you are competing
against the shiny money and you buying a
defensive home that's part of it right
yeah um
but the everyday people we're not gonna
have that problem
so
the question is how do you compete
against this crazy market
right
again
if you buy in turn key home you compete
against everybody yep if you find a home
that's not on the market
look anybody can drive so you go look at
that how's that needed to work you got
grass is cut the grass is tall the how
it looks like i need paint that's how
the knee work
anybody can write a letter to them and
call them a door knock them and ask them
would you consider selling your home i'm
looking to buy a property
and it's all timing
remember people that have a house and
need work at some point the house become
a burden for them yeah if you actually
do that enough you know like you know
like sales
you talk to enough people on average
you're going to get something yeah if
you buy those house and they work off
market you don't never have no
competition that freeway is
very little people on that freeway the
freeway that buy on the mls with that
turnkey there's a lot of traffic there i
see yeah that's how you make money real
estate damn that's a good point yeah
because sometimes those guys are looking
to let go of their house too yeah but
they're just waiting for someone to come
and ask that's right they never put the
house on the market those people the
house the house the knee worked they're
embarrassed
they don't want to clean the house out
they do much stuff yeah where would they
put it so they'd rather have somebody's
buy as is
and so they can just pack up and go
once one time
that's still good that's a really good
advice yeah yeah yeah okay another
question better to pay off student loans
first or use money to invest first suit
alone
yep why do why do you think it's student
loan or what do you say
well it depends right the student loan
is low
this person says they have a hundred and
fifty k debt when they graduate oh my
god 20 23 dude
i would say a couple things you do one
whatever you do for a living
right keep doing that get creative
there's so many different ways now to
make money online there's a time right
add
multiple more stream to make more money
and
i think
that if you're gonna buy something
i think it's better to go find multiple
ways to make money pay down your loan
and then begin buying your property
it's just a discipline thing
i think people just get a habit of just
having debt
right
i think it's you have more peace of mind
if you can just pay off that loan you
know what i mean yeah and then go buy
your property and then from there you
cut you start off with a clean slate
okay later when you get your house you
get your house payment and you got your
student loan and you get your car
payment yeah other everything payment
later on when you start buying rentals
you don't want to have a lot of bad debt
you know just get rid of some of that
to me it's more important should i pay
that off i'll buy
it's more important to get creative and
trying to find multiple more student
income yeah yeah some of the uh like
advice i've read online it's everyone
plans for when it's the sunniest
brightest day yeah but there is always a
risk no matter what it could be like
like what is it called um when there's
like a giant tornado natural disaster or
some crazy world event right the market
can crash that's right so if the market
crashes you're stuck with that loan and
your student loan
then you're like double [ __ ] yeah you
know if you you know if you don't give a
[ __ ] about peace of mind you're always
going to take the route
where it's like who cares they i call up
people that's leveraging all the time
you know what i mean yeah
i think that you can learn how to find
balance and have you know again we
talked about this earlier right uh you
know financial peace of mind and
emotional peace of mind i think it's
important yeah it is important it's very
important so i think if the interest
rate is low and your mortgage is if you
uh
is the interest rate on those student
loans low and you have a low balance for
sure you know what i mean if you can try
to do both go for it but you got a loan
like that man try to get rid of it you
know what i mean just get rid of it just
get it out of your mind yeah right get
creative go make some more money yeah
pay it off yeah that's a good that those
are some good tips
okay next question
um how would you start real estate
investing if you were to start from
scratch yes today yes and is it the
approach different now than how were the
rules different now yes today if i was
teaching anybody today
first of all everybody ultimately want
to own rental property that's the
ultimate wealth
but if you don't have no money
and no credit
you're not going to be able to own
rental
you do need some money everybody will
talk about oh you can do real estate
investment no money and no credit
i'm gonna call that [ __ ]
because the people who does all the
click bait
they didn't say
that's called whole selling
host selling when you find an off market
deal
then you tie it up
then you wholesale that contract to an
investor
and when it closed right let's say you
contract that deal with the owner for
300 and you wholesale that deal for 350
to an investor when he closed you make
fifty thousand dollar what i call a
wholesaling fee
you don't need no credit no money to do
that you just all you just found there
you just sold it and made a deal
you can do that you can make money
wholesaling
but you can't buy a house unless you are
approved from the bank and you got money
and credit
so if i was new
i teach someone
go out there and learn how to wholesale
learn how to find off market deal learn
how to evaluate learn how to make a list
of buyers so you can sell it to and
learn how to wholesale it to an investor
because
when you learn how to do that you learn
how to study the market the same way
with the guy who got money to buy you
know how to find off market you evaluate
then you learn how to make money now
instead of you wholesaling deal now
you're gonna
buy the deal yourself so you're playing
in the same sandbox the guy with money
but you don't have the money just find
the deal and just wholesale it for now
and then you work your way up the ladder
making money
find a contractor
fix and flip maybe one or two and then
fix and hold and keep us rental property
and that's how i do it today that's how
i teach all my students how to do today
that's awesome do your kids do any of
that stuff yeah my kids right now and
learn how to flip houses with me they
put their own money in with me with some
houses that's right and they have to go
to the site learn how to what people do
for a demo they have to go pick tile
pick cabinets pick carpet to learn how
to do that at 16 and 13.
that's what my kid recently had when's
the next flip they did a flip meeting
about two months ago and they're excited
they you know we gave them a percentage
of their money they invested just like a
regular investor yeah right and so now
they want the next flip that's so tight
i love that you give them the respect of
like oh you want to do some adult [ __ ]
then you gotta act like an adult that's
right that's dope like they're washing
dry machine they're washing dryer
machine in my apartment buildings right
they put their own money they buy it but
if the thing breaks they gotta fix it
with their own money oh i love that yeah
i love that that's amazing yep yeah i
don't think my parents would have ever
taught me this [ __ ] i remember i was uh
my dad uh he was a construction worker
and i'm like hey how do i do that my dad
would be like if you know how to if you
knew how to do this you wouldn't be
wanting to do this get out of here yeah
yeah okay next question uh oh wait no no
sorry okay do you advise uh to take a
real estate license and become an agent
for the first job
uh if you really want to be a salesman
and you probably want to do investing
okay
you can learn how to wholesale fire off
market and then just wholesale make
money and learn how to invest and buy
property and you don't need real estate
license to do that
okay
but if you want to get real estate
license so you can go out there and help
people put them in the car and go out
show houses like a realtor list houses
to make money
and that's your way of making money and
you'd like to be a salesman go for it so
if you'd like to be a salesman it is
worth it being getting your life right
and you want to take people out showing
houses to them i see but if you don't
care you want to just make money in real
estate yeah you don't need to do any of
that stuff you can learn how to find
off-market newcastle tv i'll make a deal
evaluate then wholesale that and make
money yeah without even dealing with a
buyer and a seller in the car yeah way
better
that does sound way better wow that's
more entrepreneurship yeah being a
realtor damn yeah i wish i would've
known all this [ __ ] growing up they
don't teach another stuff in school no i
would have listened more in school for
sure also the teachers don't know [ __ ]
in school
they don't even know reynolds themselves
yeah that's true yeah
yeah i mean that's what they need to
teach you need to teach teachers how to
have more charisma more personality be
more approachable teach better school
was [ __ ] boring
all right moving on i got that off my
chest thank you guys
um any advice for real estate in
california bay area
buying or what's b-r-r-r burr oh yeah
burst okay that's my flame okay
yes so what's burr and then the bay area
capitals so burst standpoint this is
bird's strategy how buy rental property
remember you can buy rental property
turnkey
ready to go
when you buy a turnkey credit property
you buy that market value and if you buy
another market value on mls you're going
to compete against everybody else so you
gotta pay more for it also with this
crazy market
and when you buy traditional turnkey
property
you basically put your 20 percent down
or 25 of that rental
and that's your equity which is your
down payment you don't have any other
equity
so the burr model you buy it b stands
for buy it as a fixer the worse it is
the better it is
you rehab it
then you have to get the rehab
you rent it out
after you rent it then you refi it
and get your initial down payment back
out
and then you take the down payment and
then you go buy another bird and we call
that repeat the process
so for the bay area if you want to buy
rental property anywhere
i don't care if you're in
texas
seattle
or the bay area okay
if you want to have
create wealth fast or well i'll rent
rental property
buy fixer upper
rehab the property
by the time you're done
this property let's say a turnkey profit
is worth 700 000. if you can buy a
property a fixer and we have it it's all
done and you're in it for six hundred
thousand you got an instant hundred
thousand equity
you can't do that property's already
turned key yeah so you say instant
equity
i teach people with in the bay area if
you want to have
equity in the 20 25 30 equity when
you're all done rehabbing it
you got to get creative what i call add
value and force value add value meaning
the house is already o you update what's
already there we call it add value
forcing value is you have the structure
it's a two better one bath unfinished
basement and you add more better more
bath in the basement now you bought a
two bedroom one bath but when you get it
we evaluate from the bank or appraisal
they're gonna see it's a three bedroom
two bath house with more square footage
so the appraised value go up higher yeah
or if you build like maybe a casino or
adu yeah right or you know adu so by
doing that in the bay area this is how
you can get higher margin
in equity
and you can cash flow better because now
you get multiple
you got your primary house that'll give
you rent if it's a rental then you have
your adu
as a renter so you got two sources that
help pay the mortgage on that damn
that's getting creative yes right that's
how you work around the high market to
get instant equity a lot of equity and
have a cash flow in expensive
neighborhood damn at what point are you
like the rehabbing for this property is
too long i don't want to deal with it or
you or is that not even a consideration
no because that's part of where you're
going to build your equity you just put
in your own equity in it and so
typically if you buy a house if you just
remodel a house only it could take you
three to four five months but when you
get done if you you got 20 equity that's
worth it hell yeah three four months i
think you're gonna say three four years
or something yeah you see what i mean
yeah yeah you got a house year so even a
year later right i just i just did a
deal i got a lot of dude i just did this
one deal i talked about here at the
seminar here in vegas recently
it's a single-family home i bought it
fix the single family home
for 500 000. i put 50 grand to rehab it
and then i also built a thousand square
foot adu next door
it cost me 250 000 to build this the
land was freaking i was part of my house
that property
after this all dead is worth 725 000
this 500 000 the five fifth i put into
it it's worth like 6.75
together
as it's all done here pretty soon
the value of the house and the adu
the equity in both the property together
is six hundred thousand dollar equity of
a one house single-family home wow and
it took me less than a year to do this
oh damn and i got both of those property
going at one time
okay so say i'm starting right yeah uh
and i'm trying to find and i'm trying to
repeat the process
um
who do i want on my team let's say that
i have maybe the money
but i just don't have the foresight or
the even the insight to be like oh i can
build this this and this yes like that
takes some creativity that someone that
that just has the money might not have
who do i look for first of all
if somebody would start today
i would recommend you want to make sure
that you get a mentor
right
you want to get a mentor that can
actually
at least walk with you side by side that
can actually help you see
that's the right type of property to buy
for a birthday i see
okay that's the most important thing
because not every property
is a bur property okay
so get a mentor or a coach invest in
yourself that's why i always say
once you get going you got the coaching
mentor then you're going to need an
architect
you need a general contractor
you need a relationship with a harmony
lender
and you need a relationship with a
traditional lender because a lot of
times this home really beat up
traditional bank won't finance it you
need to go hard money lending
harvard will finance it for you when
it's done though harmony is usually
short term when you get done you
refinance out of hard money you put it
into a traditional 30-year fix so that's
where the traditional bank got refi for
you
so you need a mentor
architect
general contractor right a hardware
lender
and a traditional lender and that's the
basic team you don't even need a real
estate agent
uh you could need a paid agent yeah okay
they can help you at the end to put it
up for sale but if you got to keep it as
a rental oh right i see that you don't
need them
and i teach people to manage their first
few property themselves to learn the in
and out then when you have more than
four or five six property then go ahead
and hire property manager to manage for
you that way if they do anything shiesty
you know
because you already manage your own
property yeah like that uh is managing
so say some like people like us right
that were pretty uh stretch thin at this
point um
i feel like managing is gonna take a lot
because now you're literally like hey
this is clogged or this is broken like
this thing and you're just like
if you guys if you were to open round
apartment you with the scale do you have
right then
then yes
uh first you know me and i can teach you
guys a lot of stuff about managing hey
thank you learn but then second of all
yeah you get a property manager and you
can always they can tell you how much
they charge what they're gonna do you
can all you know hate that you know uh
uh uh what do you think about this
sounds good and anybody out there
you know who has rental they can ask
their friends but you talk to me i'll
tell you yes good yes good and then boom
the proper manager managed for you and
then you're off and running
yeah nice okay i'm gonna take you up on
that yep
okay next question that was some [ __ ]
there's gems here all right i'm gonna
start charging you guys that's it i know
this episode is really this is what i
teach in my mentorship program that's
what i teach all my students how to do
that's all this stuff and i see all the
uh
the like the testimonials all the time
like this person your pharmacist yeah
this person does this school teacher or
whatever and then they're like i made my
first hundred grand in like six months
or 250 decay in equity in like a year
it's awesome i i i don't want to leave
too much of it
but
wait until the tv show come out okay
this is a tv show tv show
come on
baby there you go okay is there a is
there a date that it will come out
we are
we are at the casting uh stage right now
okay we're casting students
so the whole show is gonna be
that's doing his thing buying property
we have them doing the burr
and then
then dash is teaching all his students
how to fish we should learn how to find
ugly house we have it and keep it as
rental the burr
and so the whole show is going to be
that's teaching that's dude burr that's
teaching all his students how to do
birth all across america
and we the whole show is about teaching
how to basically own rental property
that's fixing flip there's nobody out
there that teach you how to do rental
property and the bur model too
and the goal is to um have all you know
probably you know five or six of the
student where we're gonna showcase them
through a series of uh in the season
this uh episode of everybody started
from one some you know finally ugly
houses and then ran them out right and
turned them into rental property and we
followed them throughout the whole
season sick that's amazing i love it i'm
tuning in for sure
you got to let us know when it comes out
cause i'm sure everyone wants to listen
and watch it baby let's go
okay next question
we're still good we still get okay we
gotta we got a couple more
this is so good okay fha versus
conventional loans what is better option
for first-time home buyers what's an fha
loan fbj loan is a government loan where
you can put very little money down right
and you know you don't you know your
your credit score and everything can be
lower right and uh they charge you a
little bit less interest rate you know
but the interest rate is low and you can
qualify a little easier because the
credit score is lower right
fha you can do like
three and a half percent down or three
percent out and conventional you can do
like three and a half or five percent
down so it's almost you can get in the
same but some people uh credit score is
a little lower so they can use fha
what's the pros and what's the cons of
fha then um
the
the the
for me
uh the con the pro for the conventional
is that uh you know
when you get there and after you get
like your 20 equity in it they can pull
that that mortgage insurance yeah
sometimes fha is a little bit tougher to
do that you know what i mean oh i see
but i think whatever you can qualify for
just get this get in
and then just use that vehicle to grow
your appreciation on it and then um you
know then later on when you get up
equity you know you can refi it and get
better loans on them fha two is that the
one where um you're kind of restricted
to certain areas or certain like aren't
you like capped yeah
right yeah okay yeah and conventional
you have a bigger price point you know i
mean you can get a bigger house i see
right so it's really for the beginner
but these days you know what i mean um
you know they're all great loans just
the whole keys you gotta do whatever
just get into the loan okay so for you
you're you're not saying one is better
than the other it's just getting where
you can get in get in right the whole
key is get into real estate asap take
advantage of it and then let the
appreciation right
and try to do a lot of them damn i love
that you simplify it so much where i'm
like my dumb ass brain understands it
yeah that's what everyone says they
always say uh the best time to invest
was yesterday yeah the second best time
is today yeah just get in folks the
whole key is getting in because then
every day that you wait you're wasting a
day of potential appreciation yeah yeah
get in the key is real estate is all
appreciation okay you're becoming a guru
now
just watch his videos
okay oh i think that was i think that
was it okay those were all the questions
do you have any more no those are all
the questions yeah
i see there's some more then yeah there
was a ton
you you just went boom boom boom boom
boom no but like yeah that's what i'm
saying that like uh i so i let him take
care of like the home stuff like we
there's just so many things on our plate
that we just have to split a lot of our
stuff up so if we feel one person strong
in a certain area we're like okay you
take that task on so when it comes to
like uh purchasing new homes or rental
properties i leave that uh in his hands
but when i saw your videos i was like
whoa you're explaining it in a way where
it's not intimidating and it's very
digestible it's very straightforward and
you have like this cool of explaining it
i try to keep everything simple because
it's already a very complicated thing
and people sometimes really
you know there's so much information out
you can google it what i try to do in my
video it just really inspire them and
just kick him a little bit to get him
going
it's just about getting going yeah
you're gonna figure out the how you're
gonna figure out all the what and the
who to go along with it and the key is
it's just you gotta get started and my
job to motivate them to get started
that's awesome so i got a question right
here
uh by ron bizzy should me and my partner
put down all of our life savings for a
home loan deposit oh that's a good
question home loan deposit i guess
probably their deposit for their
mortgage or their mortgage yeah oh good
question i always i always say you gotta
have reserve
for just for anything for rainy day
emergency anything right yeah if you
don't rent a property you gotta have
reserve for for home being vacant yeah
right so i don't think you should empty
it out you know i think if again we
talked about earlier if all you need was
five percent down and all you had you
had enough do ten you might have to put
five percent down keep the other five in
your pocket and then you know let the
market appreciate a little bit you know
what i mean uh uh um and um and you know
if you can make the payments you need to
get in five percent because the monthly
payment of five and ten it don't change
much but keep some of the rainy days
yeah people never think about rainy day
i'm telling you you need money for rainy
day folks yeah wasn't the stats like um
if if i think right now the american
people if um if an emergency happens
they can't even afford to dish out like
300 bucks or something like that yeah
people people right now they just they
don't think about tomorrow they think
about today only
wild
that's wild you got another one yep
um let me see you're nice you were
saying their name i didn't say anyone's
name sorry
i thank you for the questions though
okay here's a question um how do you
overcome
from the music of wolf 13
how do you overcome the fear of failure
oh man so i think that's also one thing
where a lot of people they want to
invest or they might even have the money
invest whether it's real estate stocks
crypto anything yes but they there's
always the risk of losing it right so
uh a lot of people they're like well i'm
just not even gonna move the money i'll
keep it there right but then there's
also like the
the risk of inflation where your money
that's sitting there is going to lose
value
like how do you overcome that fear right
the great thing about real estate it is
it is a very calculated risk
yeah it's not like going to the casino
and you you know rolling the dice yeah
hold on read all in red it's it's
calculated i can't speak for
other business
but first of all
if you look at real estate as a basic
if you buy a property
and
you're going to live in it let's go
let's say you say you're renting it if
you buy a property and you're going to
turn into rental
if you have some reserve and you hold it
long term you can't lose
remember anytime you ever lose you have
to sell it the only way you have to sell
it because you didn't have reserve and
also in the house when vacant
and then you can't afford to make the
payment
when the house is vacant until you find
the next tenant
that's when people have to sell their
property you know what i mean
so
to me
if you buy rental property
and you put some money down you have
some reserve
and you keep a long term it's not a
owner rental is a marathon not a sprint
if you keep a long term and you got
reserved you can go sight to all the
market
you can't lose it you know now if you're
doing the flipping game that's where the
risky game is these people out there
that fix and flip the risk is
if you're not
smart and you're not educated on
what's the price what's the real price
on this property as a fixer
what's the
after repair value probably called arv
when it's all the remodel what is it
worth
if you haven't stayed in the market long
enough and know the market area long
enough
if you missed
you think this is gonna be worth 500
when it's done
but it's worth 450.
see how fast you're 50 grand yeah
if your profits only 50 grand you
already lost it right there yeah
and if you think this property is if you
think it's worth 500
and you say this property i can buy it
for i can afford to pay 350
then you overpay you overpay for this
and then you miscalculated this
does that make sense yeah
this go down 50 grand
you pay 50 grand too much for this you
lose your ass off
if your contractor
right
says kind of cost 50 000
and he took him
instead of three months he said to him
six months you just pay too much for
interest carry costs so the flipping
game is the more risky game
the rental game is buying it you're
holding it yeah that's less risk
okay so when i say the burr model you
buying as a fixer there's risk in
buying it at the right price
getting the contractor you got to know
but since you're keeping it
there that's because you're not you're
not going to sell it do you ever sell
any of your properties like let's say
you got something and then it appraised
or it went up like crazy do you ever
cash out on the property
so when i buy a property today and i
rehab it oh i built brand new i always
go in with the intention
can this property be a burr
so to me a burr my standard for a bird
my mindset is
one
there's three ingredients that make up a
bird for me this is my standard
it has to be a proper way after i rehab
the property i buy the purchase price
and the rehab after i'm done
it has to be
all in that seventy percent of the new
arv price so listen after it's all done
i think that probably is worth 500
all into me at 350. that mean the 150 is
my 30 equity gotcha makes sense yeah so
for a bird for me i gotta have at least
30 equity
the second ingredient it has to be in
the area where the rent's high enough to
pay because i'm going to refinance and
get them work for 350 to cash out do i
get my money back because when i buy the
profit 350 i got to put 20 percent down
which is 70 000. yeah
when i
refi if i know that thing is going to be
a prey for 700 500 000 the bank will
loan me 70 percent loan the value of the
500 which is 350. so i tell the bank
just loan me 350.
so i get 100 financing on 350. i get my
dollar back out because hard money get
paid back i get my 70 percent back right
70 000 back
that rent has to cover that 350 mortgage
and some
makes sense yeah yeah and it has been
the area where they appreciate in uh
seven percent and more
every year every year so i mean double
every ten years
that's my standard i will buy if they
don't meet those three criteria then i
fix it and i flip it gotcha so every
time i walk into a deal i say to myself
does it fit these three criteria
yes yes yes this is a keeper
if it doesn't i sell it so you see how
well i calculate it when i teach all my
students these are the standard if it
hits it you're keeping it if they don't
fix it and flip it that's it that's the
standard nobody do this
that's awesome nobody we walk in knowing
what we're gonna do damn you make it
sound so easy once you know the standard
once you know things right then you're
clear yeah
you get a property and boom you know
yeah that's awesome okay so that's what
i keep and that's what i sail gotcha so
this guy is asking a question and i have
a follow-up question because i feel like
people want to know this because i
personally was in this person's shoes
and these will be the last ones okay
yeah so this guy's from nero sound 47 he
says at what age did he buy his first
property good question um and my
follow-up question to that is so
um
i grew up i would say probably
below middle class because my parents
got divorced and so my mom was a
divorced mom single woman raising a kid
by herself
and like a lot of asian uh immigrants
they just hustle hard and they're really
good at saving money so my mom
um she wasn't made she's probably making
under 30 grand a year back in like the
90s and stuff but she probably saved
like half of it that's right and she
started uh renting the rooms out so we
had a four bedroom house
and me and my mom lived in one room
right and she rented the other three so
now the other three rentals uh were able
to pay for the mortgage of the home so
we technically lived in the house for
free even though we had strangers all
the time so there's definitely cons to
it definitely weird but you got creative
and you got resourceful right yeah your
mom was doing airbnb for everybody
yeah that's funny i didn't even think
about it sometimes better breakfast too
because she's making food i shared with
people
and so um so she was crushing it and
then she was able to finally save enough
and buy her own rental house rental
property right
so i saw that so i saw like the
the workings of it that's right and when
i was like 21 22 23 i understood this
concept and i understood i could
probably save one of my weekends to
hustling to getting another job and
making money and start with my own
rental that's right but then also has a
21 22 year old you want to party you
want a party yeah
that's the hard part so you're like so
you got like this part where you're like
this is what i should be doing that's
right but then you also want to do this
like how did how old were you because i
knew you were young when you
first bought your own house like how did
you fight those yes those early 20s
urges yes all right so first ques first
question
um
i bought my first rental property in
1997.
um
how old are we talking about uh i was um
27 years old okay okay that's a pretty
good age yeah that's really great yeah
um
now i bought it as a first-time
homebuyer okay the house is 120 000. i
still own it today
i put down five percent
which is a little over six thousand
dollar
and then i decided to leave my mom and
dad steal and not turn into a rental how
did you even have the
you know like a lot of kids they they
want to immediately flex right like i
don't live at home no more right how did
you even fight that right
so first of all back then they didn't
have social media so people wouldn't
flex as much
yeah i mean
so
um
cami was the real
boss this is your wife this is my wife
cami yeah so me and cammy were living at
my mom and dad's house right
and so
when we bought our first rental right
which is we we bought it as own occupy
and then we turned it into rental and we
stay there
and um and then
today man that property about 120 you
guys i want to put down 60 but 25 down
we did some minor updating here and
there throughout the year the house is
still in good condition it's worth 750
000 today wow it's free and clear i get
three thousand dollars a month for rent
that's just purely appreciation see yeah
a five a six thousand dollar investment
with some minor repair here and there
not a major remodel and it turned into
what's 750 minus 120 let's call it 600
grand with equity damn imagine i got
hundreds of those okay so now i have a
follow-up question to your follow-up
question so i know there's gonna be a
lot of guys that are already asking like
how do i get a girl how do i get a girl
but you not only got the girl but you
brought her back to live with your
parents how did you do that that is
tough yeah that's tough yeah my mom and
dad you know i mean they you know
they're easy going you know what i mean
and they was cool you know what i mean
and um and cammy and i you know what i
mean you know we were easygoing so you
know how did you so she you she you
didn't have to convince her you didn't
have to go like you know
yeah i
uh well you know cameron and i were
dating you know you know you know of
course they always come over you know to
our house or i go to her house you know
me and the mom and dad they got to know
us you know what i mean and you know i i
started realizing young you know i was
hustling i think parents when they see
their kid hustling they have respect for
the guy that's true you know
this guy's not a loser you know what i
mean yeah right and and this guy's
hustling you know he's selling real
estate he's hustling and so you know and
then you know you know it started with
as simple as cammy would you know her
and i'll be out and about and sometime
you know uh you know cam will get home
late at night 10 o'clock and then
sometime you know later on she get home
at 11 o'clock and then i'll get home at
one o'clock and eventually you know she
never came home she stayed at my house
you know what i mean and then one day
her mom was like at that you know tell
cameron to come home it's in the morning
now oh okay right and then you go home
right and then you know that kind of
schedule sometimes you go home sometimes
you know she stay and then eventually
her mom and everything wouldn't even
trip anymore because you know they can't
see us right yeah so
but the thing was
cami
and i had been this a hustler from day
one
and i think they asked you a question
for you bro about being young i want to
kick it we were always hanging out with
each other you know what i mean yeah
yeah we were playing tennis together
right we worked that safe way together
when we were younger you know what i
mean i got into real estate early and
then she came on later
and we were just hustling together and
we did everything together and when
you're doing everything together we'll
go out kicking it together go eat
together we'll go make money together
and it was just we wasn't feeling like
we're losing you know what i mean i
think when someone who's young and they
don't have anybody yet
it's a different story you know what i
mean they want to get their they want to
get your groove on they want to get
deflects on they want to do things
but i'm going to tell the young people
today
if you buy a property
and you let
the renter pay for your property or you
pay the monthly payment it's gonna take
you 30 years to pay it off so if you're
25 years old and you just
let the mortgage pay yourself you're
gonna take 30 years to pay one off okay
i'm gonna give you a little bonus right
now
if you
pay if you make the payments 12 months
right and at the end of the year you
make one extra payment with the 13
payment and you drop that
straight to principle you will shave off
seven and a half years of your loan wow
whoa okay should we be doing that with
this house too of course my one extra
payment drop it i might do two extra
payments
principal now
the point i'm making for young folks
right now when you're young you got a
long runway
don't kill so much you run away and all
of a sudden you get to 35 now you run
away short cuz
you want to get to a position where you
have my aid at 50 where you have enough
passive income where you can work when
you want to work where you want to work
who you want to work with so when you're
in your 20s
go have fun but don't waste all that
invest go work save you money buy a
couple rental make some extra payment
so 15 years from now 20 years from now
you're gonna have three or four houses
paid off by the tenant
now you're living on a big retirement
plan right there you got a gang at net
worth you got some good cash flow
now you can work and i work for me i
still work every day because you want to
because i want to have to which is the
best way so that's what i would say to
the young people
don't think oh i got plenty of time you
don't because the moment you get into
your 30 now you only got 20 years before
you're 50
because a lot of times you're 50 you
don't want to work that much and you
ain't going to want to work because you
got kids now and you got family and your
energy is less right you don't have the
same motivation you don't have the same
drive your goal is different you're
going to want to hang out with your
family more and you're not going to be
like me you're 51 years old that's how
i'm 51 years old you're not going to
have to say ambition keep doing what
like what you're doing yeah yeah so
don't kill too much of your runway when
you young folk you don't have that much
time okay go have fun but also be
responsible i love it that's awesome
that also sounds like too um
because you found who mattered the most
in your life early
that you didn't really have imaginary
people to impress that's right because i
think you know like for me when i was i
didn't meet her until we were like 27 or
28 but in the early ages when you want
to get your groove on and kick it you're
really going to the club or even on
social media you're just doing things to
impress people that don't really matter
that's right and it's really pulling
yourself away from the things that
actually matter that's right when like
where you you're like well i already
have my ride or die chick we play tennis
we do whatever we hang out all that
together right outside of that i'ma
hustle really hard so i think like to
all the young kids out there young
people out there like be really focused
on whom who matters the most in your
life yeah and if they're happy you're
happy then the next thing you should do
is focus on yourself i'm gonna add to
that
find a mentor
who you really can respect
beyond money
right who has money and balance yeah
right and quality and integrity
and then go and see where they let you
in turn that's how lorenz met me
he was only interested
in all right shout out to mr lorenz
right yeah he came to me when he was
young when he was like he's 27 now he
can't meet when he was like 24 and he
asked me can i run your social media for
free
right let me help you mark man and so
since lorenzo hang with me
i taught him about business i taught him
about so many things so now he's hungry
as a young age to start to buy his
property and start stacking his thing so
for the young folks out there you don't
have a that's right in your life you can
go find people around you that's already
doing things go see if you can interrupt
them for free
and go give something of value for them
for free let them let you be psychic
with them for a little bit
like when you hang out with them you're
going to have someone else speaking
something different in your ear versus
all your friend
people [ __ ] anyways nothing
and that's how you actually can get
going faster too that's awesome i love
that i love that you're teaching that
i'm about to wrap it up uh because we've
reached the end of this but um yeah i
feel like that needs to be spoken over
and over again i feel like this
generation i sound old now i sound like
my [ __ ] parents but yeah i feel like
this in this generation right now feels
like well what are you gonna do for me
instead of it being like wait i have
nothing
uh like my my knowledge is so low let me
just intern or let me like volunteer my
time so that like i can learn for free
that's right so i love that you're
saying it that way yeah
on that note
damn i hate always saying bye because
this is so rad this is so fun you're
great energy you're just you're i'm just
so happy you're here thank you so much
for your time thank you for everyone who
submitted your questions um i'm going to
leave all his information in the
description box below so you can find
him um thank you again
my pleasure
i appreciate it remember i told you
earlier
let's use this platform
to inspire and empower other people
but together
let's leave a big ass mark on the planet
way better than it is when we came in
hey
i can stand behind that let's go okay
thank you so much and we'll catch you
guys next week